foreign
Durango Colorado
that's not even a place Colorado what's
up hope I don't even know where that
accent came from what's up how are you
I I mean
just have the time in my life running a
scam here called a podcast what are you
up to
just working taking a break to talk to
you
awesome so let's solve this problem
what's up yes so my question is how do
you know when it's time to
stop trying for another baby and going
through recurrent losses and kind of
move forward with life oh gosh let's
don't solve that one that was really
hard
it's a big one for a Monday yeah
um gosh
oh man
um
so how many losses
um so our story
um my husband and I've been married for
almost five years
we got pregnant the first time a month
after we got married
and uh lost that pregnancy about a month
later and then found out that there was
actually a second baby in that pregnancy
that was in my fallopian tube it
ruptured and I came pretty close to
dying before I had emergency surgery yep
um we got pregnant two more times that
year lost both of those and then uh
fourth pregnancy seemed like it was
going in the right direction finally and
then I got the same debilitating pain
and sure enough it was another ruptured
ectopic had my second tube removed in
emergency surgery
um we
are Big Dave Ramsey followers so we
saved up in cash flow to do IVF because
that was our only option for me to carry
our baby at that point
um did IVF our first transfer Embryo
transfer was perfect our embryo split
into identical twin boys and they are
wonderful they're two and a half now
yeah two for one there and then we
decided to start trying for baby number
three in January transferred again that
embryo also split and would have been
identical twin girls but we lost them
and then just last month we were gonna
try one more time to do a transfer and
hope that it would work and like a few
days before my
um scans just weren't looking very good
and so it got canceled and
but I felt like I had had a lot of time
to like recover from the previous losses
but going through these last two cycles
just really put me back in that really
difficult space and I just don't know if
it's time to move forward and just enjoy
the boys that we have
or what
so I want to preface this with this is a
deeply deeply personal
um decision okay
yeah
um this is a decision between you and
your husband this is a decision about
identity and a decision about there's so
many different decisions here okay
um
I want to talk to you broadly and then
we'll get very specific okay and I'm not
going to sugarcoat anything and I need
you to know if we were having this
conversation in person I would go a lot
slower than I'm going to go today okay
okay is that fair
yeah okay I am really worried about
your marriage
this is a lot of loss
in a very short amount of time
yeah and I it's statistically speaking
the ice y'all are on is so thin
um
you you know exactly what I'm talking
about don't you
yes yeah we came very close to not
making it to even have our boys because
it was so hard that first year yeah
challenges grief um as the great David
Kessler says is like a fingerprint it's
Unique to everybody and when you go
through loss like this especially
miscarriage it's hard to discuss in it's
hard to even know right because it feels
a certain way and then there's there's
hormones but then there's also loss and
then people feel it differently and
think differently about it
and you've got one of you saying well
I'm ready to try again you get the other
person like I can't breathe you what are
you talking about what's the matter with
you and it's when you get to the what's
the matter with you or what do you mean
we're just gonna stop and just sit here
for a year so you start grieving
separately
and when you start grieving separately
you create two different worlds right
and then somebody at work is a little
bit funny or a little bit nicer or a
little bit we can talk about something
else and then all of a sudden you're
down hatch number one or down hatch
number two so just starting broadly for
the sake of your marriage I would tell
you to take a break
yeah
just need to Exhale for a season
um
and y'all haven't even had a chance to
be married yet y'all got thrown right
into the middle of a scorcher right
yeah for sure
um
how old are you
I'm 31. okay why this it almost feels
manic why why the
push push push push go go go go go go
I yeah it definitely felt that way until
we had our boys and I I just have always
wanted to be a mom I've always wanted to
have a huge family and I think manic
probably is a good term for how I felt
um like just as soon as one loss was
over it was time to try for the next one
and how did y'all how'd you all grieve
the loss of those um pregnancies
everybody does it different so there's
not a right or wrong way
I
um I'm really open about
shared a lot about it with just friends
and family
yeah you're sharing the process
how did you agree those individual
losses
I we moved forward really quickly I have
the name of every one of the pregnancies
that me and my wife have lost which are
three tattooed on my body
oh wow okay
and it's not for everybody
but
there's something profound about
stopping
and acknowledging loss
even if you aren't that like man it
wasn't a baby yet whatever wherever you
fall on that Spectrum which is a whole
other conversation
the moment you find out your pregnancy
a dream is cast out ahead of you right
oh yeah you start making plans
and you start building rooms and you
start
um
you start imagining and it's really hard
to just let that thing dissipate and go
you have to honor that man a path just
laid out in front of us and that path is
over
mm-hmm you know what I mean
some people do it by writing letters
to the the baby that they lost some
people write poetry some people call
some friends over and have a formal
Funeral Service some people come over
and and just say hey
we want to acknowledge this together
this is a heavy season for us we lost
this
but just blowing by it and blowing by it
and blowing by it seven times that's a
lot that your body's carrying for you
yeah definitely
have you been open with your
um husband about the nature of these
losses
yeah yeah we're very open with each
other about all of them okay
you're calling for a reason are you
calling because you want permission to
stop
or do you want permission to keep going
I
almost think it's permission to stop
okay I need you to hear me say and I'm
gonna speak for everybody in humanity no
one can give you that permission that's
for you
foreign
but you have my permission to stop
and you're gonna have to grieve that
dream that you're gonna have 14 kids
running around
and Alder knuckleheaded girlfriends and
boyfriends and party you're gonna have
to grieve that
and just because you grieve that picture
doesn't mean you don't love recklessly
these two knuckleheaded twin boys you
got
it's both and
but I think it's worthy of writing
yourself
your future self a letter
the 52 year old you that was going to
have six kids running around
and honor her
because man we just just listening to
your story y'all went down swinging
right
but it's almost scary to reimagine your
marriage right now isn't it
yeah we just feel like I've never had
time to do anything fun like we're
taking a family vacation at the end of
this month and that's like we never even
had a honeymoon like we just hope
it is not you are not going on vacation
you've heard that old saying if it's
just you and your spouse that's vacation
if you go with your kids it's a trip
you're going on a trip at the end of
this month with two twin two and a half
year old boys there is going to be pee
and poo flying airware
and diapers and naps and shenanigans and
you sitting reading a book in the
bathroom of a hotel like that that's
just gonna be what this trip is
yeah but you can also find the
resounding joy in this little four this
little gang of four this is going to
take on the world
yeah it's just hard to like reimagine
place I guess when you were expecting it
to be different it is
it's hard it's devastating
yeah I think go ahead it's hard to not
have like
and I almost wanted like a second chance
at pregnancy because theirs was just so
terrifying because of all the losses
before and so I was like this next
pregnancy I'm gonna do all these things
differently and then I hope
none of this loss was your fault
I remember sitting with the woman one
time who looked up at me through through
tear-soaked eyes and she said the
following I'm tired of my body killing
babies
and I just hugged her and I didn't say
another word because there wasn't
anything else to say
and what I should have told her was
not your fault
because you have spent the last five
years
trying to reverse engineer every step
you took and every meal you had and
every bout of gas and diarrhea and
everywhere you've tried to reverse
engineer at all
it's not your fault
okay
yeah Hope's not broken and hope didn't
do anything wrong
is that fair
yeah okay
the scariest question you and your
husband have to answer
is not are we going to have any more
the scariest question you'll have to
answer is
what are we gonna do now
and who are we gonna be now
yeah
and the beautiful thing is you all get
to choose
are we going to forgive each other
for how we did or didn't respond
are we going to
work really hard to alter our mindset
towards being comically overly grateful
for these two Rascals we got
and Our Gang of four
and are we going to properly sit in
grief for what wasn't
right you have to walk through all that
stuff
yeah
you just can't avoid it
but I would definitely take a break how
many
um embryos do you have out
we have
six more
[Laughter]
that's incredible you're gonna have 111
kids hope yeah we had five boy embryos
and three girl embryos and we were like
boy if they split every time that's a
lot of kids
oh the hope
geez
I mean there's going all in you're like
I'm going all in and you put your car
keys on the table and your house deed on
the table
I can't make those calls for you okay
that's between you and your husband but
I would definitely recommend taking a
break for for a while
yeah okay and you know this when you get
to be 34 35 they start telling you that
you're a thousand years old
yeah and that you're this Grandma trying
to have a baby which is just stupid
okay
yeah you got time
if time is even something you want to go
down that road
but what you'll have to do right now is
spend some time healing your marriage
healing yourselves you gotta grieve
these losses that's a lot of loss you
gotta grieve your body that in your
heart and mind failed you
but you also got to make peace with it
because that's the only one you got
yeah
you got to make peace you gotta grieve
that future we're gonna have that we're
probably not gonna have it's gonna look
very different and it's still gonna be
awesome it's just gonna be different
kind of Awesome
Fair
yes
I'm really grateful that you called
thank you thanks for your time
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you a copy of own your past change your
future actually I'm gonna send you two
one for you and one for your husband and
it really is the path
here's where you go when all the wheels
fall off and all the plans we had going
this way suddenly or there's that road
implodes and what do we do now
so hang on the line here I'm going to
send you a couple of copies of that
um
and you call anytime
if I can help you with the grieving
process if I can be anyway I've been
down this road
um personally so
um
thanks for being brave
used to do everything new